the vice president's trip scheduled for
tomorrow after 93 days
more than three months after she was
tapped to lead the administration's
response to the surge of illegal
immigrants
but just days after former president
donald trump announced
he was going to head to the border
upstage by the vp
let's see if it'll happen it hasn't
happened yet we're watching so
what's been keeping kamalahara so busy
that she couldn't find the time in the
last
more than three months to visit the
border a quick check of her schedule
finds that in april she visited a bakery
in chicago
delicious is that the one where she
baked the cookies with her face on it
yup
there they are speaking of baked goods
the passed out cookies and her likeness
to reporters while she was traveling to
meet the president of guatemala that was
part of her trip to the northern
triangle countries only she just went to
one she didn't go to the other two
important because a lot of people coming
across the border from honduras and
well you know from the looks of the
picture she had a good time there
the vice president also smiled while
joining marchers for the capital pride
parade earlier this month now we're not
saying that that's not important
and the traveling that she's been doing
to to talk about vaccinations for
covid19 also important just days later
she hosted a dinner party inviting all
the female senators
where she apparently also found the time
to make her own cheese puffs
but no planned visit to the border until
yesterday
what changed our peter ducey tried to
find out
was it important for the white house to
have her
seen at the border before former
president trump has a trip there next
week
we made an assessment within our
government about when it was an
appropriate time for her to go to the
border
an assessment three months in uh tommy
laron is here
and so is juan williams a lot of
breaking news and you two are along for
the ride this hour as well so welcome
outnumbered loves you tommy you've spent
so much time at the border
and lieutenant governor of texas dan
patrick told me last hour that
going to el paso is like going to boston
when the crisis is in d.c
not that they don't have their problems
with this issue in el paso texas
but it's not the epicenter of what he
would really like for the vice president
to see
you know listen yesterday when we heard
that vice president kamala harris was
indeed going to the border my first
thought was let's make sure we clarify
which border
because we know that she's the queen of
semantics so i was very concerned that
she wouldn't be headed to the right one
but i'm happy to find that she is indeed
going to our southern border yes el paso
is not really the epicenter
of what's happening right now i would
much prefer she'd go down to rgv go to
mcallen texas there are several areas
even going to arizona would be
beneficial
but i'm just happy she's going to the
border and who do we have to thank for
that well
we have our former president donald j
trump to thank for that one after he
pledged to go to the border then i guess
it turned up the heat
on vice president kamala harris and 90
some days later
she's finally headed to the border but
i'll tell you harris this is my biggest
concern
my biggest concern is that she is going
to tour and she's going to see detention
facilities or processing centers
and then my concern is that she's going
to pass off the failures
and pass it off on to border patrol and
somehow further demonize them in the
work that they've done
so i really hope that that doesn't
happen but we've seen this time and time
again with democrats whenever they have
a problem that they've
created they find out who to pass it off
on and oftentimes it's those in law
enforcement in this case
border patrol and ice all right juan i'm
going to come to you next but i i want
to go to kaylee real quickly because
the head of border patrol under trump
was allowed to
stay right we saw a change in that
position an announcement of a change in
that position politically behind the
scenes take us there
yeah behind the scenes they're in
absolute chaos i mean they didn't take
this seriously they were warned as
you've been told on the airwaves that
they would
cause a problem if they disrupted the
trump era policies and they did just
that but i
it confounds me harris uh so they're
trying to placate their left-wing base
of course by rolling back the trump era
policies title 42 was one
such basically saying we'll let children
in we're not going to use covet as a
reason to keep children out
well now amid this fire on our southern
border
they are going to roll back even more of
title 42 and allow families to come in
why when you have a raging forest fire
on the border that jinsocki's trying to
dismiss she's saying that we've made
progress
meanwhile yesterday was the highest
number of unaccompanied minors we've
seen
since the spring when you have a raging
fire why do you throw kerosene on it by
rolling back
yet more of trump's policies what's your
thought on that my thought is placating
aoc they are terrified of losing the aoc
ilhan omar wing of the party uh they
depend on that wing
and they know they're losing it them day
by day as
long as they allow some of the trump
error policies all right our uh
left-leaning strategist and guru
juan williams is with us today what do
you say to kaylee on that
well i think people are playing politics
with immigration look
you know the reality is that if going to
the border
solve the immigration problem for our
country uh this problem would have been
solved years ago
the idea is that uh harris is not
i think responding to trump or anybody
else
i think that you know i think that she
went down to
guatemala and mexico with announcements
she said don't come
it's not safe don't believe the cartels
when they tell you that
the president of the united states
policies are saying something completely
different
hang on harris can i speak for a second
yes okay so i think she went down there
with a clear
message an announcement also that she
was going to help in terms of u.s
funding for fighting against the cartels
and against the coyotes
and asking them for cooperation and
sending that message
to the people the migrants that are
desperate you know
faced with violence political oppression
and the cartels so that's why she went
there
going to the border you would think that
a president or a vice president
would have something to announce now i
don't know what it is that
she has to announce but i i'm looking
forward to it
clearly what we have at the moment is
real
progress we have had real progress
especially
in dealing with the uh immigration of
minors but now we see the single adults
that's popped up more
but overall what you see is that they're
making an effort to actually cope with
this i just think
three days afterwards missing an action
congress won't do
anything you see republicans go let's go
down for a selfie
the congress has the power of the person
and the
power to act and the congress won't act
in 2013
that i think you have president has the
power like a dozen or more republicans
who had i'm saying right now majority
you could have you could have rubio you
could have graham you could have
republicans agree to what they agreed to
in 2013
and get 40 million plus in terms of
border security
but but right now because they're
playing to the outrage on the right
they won't they won't vote for anything
they won't deal with this problem they
just want to play politics
right and one i just wanted to continue
the dialogue with you here
in that i think part of the frustration
that people feel
is that the vice president by by not
engaging with and going to the border
she's not hearing them she's not seeing
what's actually happening
because what we keep hearing from the
boots on the ground there border patrol
ice landowners there american citizens
there is that the problem is
overwhelming it's a forest fire to use
kaylie's words
so people are hoping by her physical
presence maybe then she'll know because
there hasn't been a communication
at the local and state level with the
federal government that's the pattern we
keep hearing
and we now learn today in the past hour
with you harris the lieutenant governor
there
dan patrick in texas he talked about the
fact that he had yet to receive an
invitation
by or communication from the vice
president as he said it
you don't just invite yourself to her
motorcade and so i think the questions
remain
why is the vice president then
potentially just checking a box because
it seems like from what we know
right now to your point as well you
expect an announcement
well then there's going to be no
engagement if the guys on the
on the ground now can't even depend on
her to have a conversation
to have her see what they're going
through and have that conversation that
that we at least can have here for five
minutes
what actually will be done so what's
interesting about that question well i
think
i think alexander i think the the
secretary of homeland security
and the department of homeland security
has been there repeat
has been there repeatedly so it's not a
lack of communication emily i think
those
officials have had many chances to speak
with federal officials the people in
charge
of customs and border patrol we've seen
additional resources sent
i think you have a clash in terms of
people saying what
should be done and of course you have
the overly political angle of some
people saying well
let's go back to trump-era policies
which you know family separation the
rest
so many saw that as not only abusive and
harmful but non-american in terms of our
values
no doubt about it it's not a matter of
lack of communication there's
you know i mean when you talk about
what's happening to children and the
fact that some of them don't even have
the supplemental food that they need and
it's not prepared in a safe way in some
areas we are
overwhelmed here we're taking care of so
many of them
you can throw barbs if you want at a
former president but my goodness
i don't know that we would see kamala
harris going to the border if it hadn't
been for that former president
we don't know because she hasn't said
anything and if she's gonna announce
something
i hope she stays on the ground longer in
you know el paso on this side of the
border
longer than she did in guatemala and
mexico because our reporters on the
ground said
they saw a lot more than she did kaylee
yeah and the question is is kamala going
to go to those emergency facilities
where we knew no children are attempting
suicide
on her watch she used to call this human
rights abuse but
no longer apparently so i'd like to see
her go to one of those facilities but i
went to brian kilmeade i want you to do
me a favor i want you to click to
subscribe to the fox news youtube page
this is the only way that i know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great
news bites any great interviews coming
your way on fox
you can get it all here on youtube so
subscribe
right now